are you a modern woman or are you a
traditional woman in that relationship
and can you tell me
why how what makes you think now
I'm gonna go first
[Music]
um
I think I'm modern
but I still hold a lot of Traditional
Values
100 expand on their Traditional Values
so in terms of like in my relationship I
definitely cater to my man
I just still believe it can you speak
into the microphone please yeah I still
believe in like
I cook for him I clean for him and like
he comes home his slippers are at the
top of the stairs I take pride in that
still but then I'm still very much like
in a modern relationship if that makes
sense
so I do it I have a lot of traditional
venues but we're in a modern
relationship so you've told me the
Traditional Values what are the modern
values that you think you have so I
could dress how I want
I can speak to everyone I have male
friends I dance how I want I drink as
much as I want and I feel like that's
very modern because I have I have older
brothers and stuff like that and that
that stuff doesn't run for them but in
my relationship it does but then I still
have Traditional Values I cook for him I
clean for him on my days off because we
both work and stuff so when I'm not
working I'm cooking for him his pajamas
are folded on the pillow his slippers
are left at the top of the stairs but
it's still like a very modern
relationship because I would dress in
that skimpy little dress I would drink
as much tequila as I want and I'll stay
out till I want so I feel like we have a
very
um
a very good balance of modern and
traditional
I think that's that's how it works these
days okay
yeah I'd kind of say the same because I
like like to I believe in the
Traditional Values like cooking and just
keeping home as a woman so I do agree
with that but at the same time I think
like you could still live your life you
could still go out and socialize up with
your friends I guess traditionally women
wouldn't really go out or like things
like girls holidays going to Ibiza
things like that I think that's okay it
happens you know as well no nothing
happens but yeah so I wouldn't a
traditional woman go to Ibiza
um it's just like I guess drinking party
holiday it's kind of like not the norm
back then I guess but now it is because
it's like that's the modern thing that's
normal
so
both of your partners would have would
let you or would be okay with you going
on ladies holidays I have some kind of
yeah we've spoken about this so yeah
yeah my boyfriend 100 has it happened
um yeah kind of at the beginning stages
but yeah it was kind of like but now
it's kind of like um maybe sometimes not
as much maybe why not because I've been
going a lot so obviously in the past so
what's the difference between going then
and going you just got to consider
someone else's feelings and yeah
because I guess you've got to treat
someone how you would want them to treat
you so it's like if he was going all the
time like freelance holidays yeah I
wouldn't like it so you're losing your
modern values and gaining more
traditional ones yeah
okay young man you're in a relationship
yes what makes your young lady work for
you is she modern or is she traditional
um I think more than what Traditional
Values like what she what they said
what does she do for you how do you mean
what does she do for me they said I want
to know what she actually does for you
um she brings me peace and that's
something that I haven't found
um and the last show I was talking about
dealing with problem problematic boss
[ __ ] per se
um and I think one of the most important
things that I've I've found as I've
grown up and the women is that I just
want peace I'm a hard-working individual
um I know what I want and one of the
things I want is just peace and a fun
person someone I can do things with I'm
someone that needs to be taken out of
their comfort zone a little bit
sometimes and I think with the right
woman they're gonna make you do things
and come outside of yourself out of your
comfort zone a little bit so I think
that's what I don't need there's a lot
of things that I thought I needed before
I don't even need those things such as
um
I thought maybe I needed a woman that
was supposed to support me and from the
from the ground up and helped me
business or whatever and and support me
and be there and that that whole story
of probably what my parents had and what
a lot a lot of people had but I also
understand that that for a lot of women
that can be hard and you know a lot of
men might want the woman that's going to
be around from when they had nothing and
to grind up but in reality it doesn't
always happen for people so I also think
that as long as you're willing to go out
and get as a man then you might meet
that person later on and if you've got
some of that stuff as long as you can
bring you peace and some of the things
that you need to figure out that's the
most important thing for me
so having your woman going out drinking
tequila oh
wearing skimpy clothes going out with a
friend's toy before will she still fit
your no why not those are problems for
me as they were saying it I just said on
the left she was saying that I keep my
male friends I wear what I want I go
where I want
um and then the right she's saying well
I used to do some of those things but
now I've got a man I don't do that thing
and you're asking why because you
understand that your man's not going to
be happy about that I think at some
point you have to understand that
you can't do some of the same things
that you did when you're single in your
relationship like you know and with a
lot of these modern women they want to
do they want to have the cake and eat it
so you can't be well you can because you
know a woman has the right to choose you
can choose what you want to wear and all
of that stuff but if you have a partner
you need to think about how that can how
that part how that can be perceived and
also not putting yourself in an
environment some places where it allows
you to be you know
isn't perception a personal thing though
how do you mean so you're saying how it
can be perceived if a girl wants to go
away and not have fun enjoy a holiday of
our friends and be completely loyal I
don't see the issue well it depends who
she's going on holiday with is she going
on holiday with five other girls that
are all in relationship or is she the
one person in relationship going with
four single girls now if she's going
with four single girls now it's no one
to tell what those single girls should
do on holidays so if they want to be on
a table for example and then you know
let's um some guys throw some bottles
open ask them to go on a table those
single those four single girls entitled
to do what they want to do but the
problem lies now your girl is in this
position now so she can't be the one
asking him that actually girls I can't
do it because she's ruining the party so
now she puts herself on the table
alcohol intoxication things are
happening right now
um and then men are moving to your girl
now she's not going to have it because
she's your girl she's gonna like look
I've got a man and the rest of it but at
the same time now you put yourself your
girl in a position where you have men
that are now like so where's your man
why is your man not here if he was my
girl I wouldn't let you I'll be out here
with you right now you start to have
some of those things and you see that
saying when they say I was drunk it was
a mistake that's never happened in a
scenario when someone wasn't drunk and
it was a mistake so how do we get
ourselves out some of these scenarios by
not putting ourselves in these scenarios
but if you know how to hand yourself in
that scenario then it doesn't matter if
you're in that scenario or not and if
you know how to trust your girl then
there's nothing to do about trust I
don't trust men no listen no I agree I
agree I went out of town one at a time
so okay so this is one of the things
that we need to understand in life right
like I've got I've got um Three Sisters
I spoke about them before my sisters are
married and the child I had a younger
sister that was directly under me and I
used to look after I went to like we
used to go travel to school and the rest
of it a lot of things that we we talk
about they come from a point of Love see
when your mom used to
say to you or where you're going to be
or what time you're going to be home who
are you with she didn't do that because
she didn't care she did it because she
loved you I see there's something that's
that's been missing when men do this we
don't do this because we're trying to
stop you if you're happiness we'll do
this because we generally love you you
as a woman might not see some of the
dangerous us men have seen and what we
understand so I can't treat every man
that that's going to be out there that
has been raised by by in a two in a in a
loving home he's going to treat women
like this a lot of times as you've seen
men and other people in these in these
um in in these situations they can act a
certain way so all I'm saying is I'm not
saying I don't trust her I'm not saying
that the other people you don't trust
yeah and it's the scenario so one of the
ways you can avoid this is by not
putting yourself in certain scenarios
that's all I'm saying and when you have
a partner and someone that obviously
um you consider that you love you have
to think about how they make may
consider things I get it but at the same
time then your your restricting her from
what she's up exactly from where she's
going no no she's like babe look on the
girls again X1 XYZ on this on a Hindu or
the girls want to go away to XYZ are you
stuck on that yes
I think like you've got a your
girlfriend's gotta think you know what
kind of friends am I going out with
because as a girl you know how your
friends are so you know like if this if
I go with these two friends they're
gonna be like that that shows your
woman's week no no but it does no but
I'm saying like you can say you know
what I'm not gonna put myself in that
position so she should make the Judgment
for herself just all right the guy let
me jump on that when you say position
what position is she putting herself
like for example say if you go on a
girl's holiday and your friends are
there and they're single as he said and
you they invite a load of lads back and
then they're sleeping together and your
girl's just there like go to bed
it's like that sort of situation say
it's like happens like you you can't
what happened but if something happens
if something happens then you're
allowing that to happen like I have a
lot of single friends I'll go on a
holiday I love my boyfriend so [ __ ]
much I'm I'm so loyal yeah but I could
still have two single friends and
they're linking up with guys but I would
tell my boyfriend like oh these these so
and so are talking to these guys but he
knows I'm not doing anything yeah I do
the same but at the same time they're
not going to want you in that situation
of course in a room with free guys
it's not about what situation you put
yourself in it's how you handle yourself
in the situation can I answer your
question when you go out
and your dress is a certain way and
you've got a partner who are you
representing who are you presenting
myself
you're not presenting yourself as your
Man's partner you're not representing
your man you're just going out as
you yeah yeah I'm going out with me
right so okay to the young man if you're
a woman that you've got now we're now in
skimpy clothes drank tequila went to
ibifa would you believe that she's
representing you how would you expect
because I'm look I'm listening to what
you said about perception and I'm
thinking
a hen night
in a spa with female friends having
their makeup and they're done jacuzzi
never your nails done but was a
champagne nothing wrong how is that
perceived rather than hen night skimpy
clothes tequila dancing on tables
in Ibiza I think a lot of what is the
perception how does it look so that's
what he's saying about how it's
perceived how does it look and does he
want his woman
representing him in that way bro look
for example right like the problem of
this is is
you can do whatever you want now you can
do whatever you want but the moment you
have a partner you need you're not by
you do represent them so how many how
men look at other men is we judge them
so we don't just judge you about how
much money you have do you understand so
when you're outside and you rep I know
that's your man over there and we can
see in the nightclub how you act
reflects on him it's a reflection of how
much no it is because if you respect him
you want to do certain things if you
thought he was worthwhile you would
realize actually people know who my man
is I want to do certain things so when
you're outside in a public place you
represent your man whether or not you
like it or not whether or not you like
it or not you do you need to be specific
like grinding on another geez is a
different story but if you're just
dancing enjoying yourself a bunch of
girls wait we never seen you've got to
be specific we didn't say anything about
dancing
so we need to split we need to split
enjoying versus out there potentially
um disrespecting or perceptions of other
people if my girl is out I don't want
any of my friends to send me a video
saying oh why is your girl on This
Girl's On this man's table that in
itself enough that one above me it won't
bother you no sugar insecure one bit
listen this is this is why I see Life
yeah if you've got a goal and you trust
her and she trusts you and you've got a
loving relationship if she's gonna cheat
she's going to cheat
when did he mention
because my girlfriend my potential wife
should not be on another table another
man you that's in security
I'm trying to let him say what you're
saying because I think he's means it's a
sense of respect like you guys are you
have to understand something this is the
modern thinking you want to have a man
you want to have all the benefits of a
man a loyal guy that's not do you want
your man out there sleeping other women
I'm asking a question but why does that
mean I'm not I didn't say you was I'm
asking you a question okay so okay us as
men and women we look at loyalty
different things by what you're doing
that is actually disloyal and if you
can't see it it's because you're not a
man and I'm trying to try would you do
that to your man what what I'm saying
knowing that you got a man now you're
gonna actively go out there saying I
want to wear what I want I'm gonna go
out who I want I'm gonna do all these
things doesn't matter what my man thinks
because that's the case then just no I
would wear what I want because I feel
like I don't really you wearing clothes
I think that's a that's you and yours
but at the end of the day I think in
general you would think of your man in
certain situations so so when you so so
when you so so when you went out to
Canada for example in it yeah so you're
gonna tell me you're gonna wear a little
boy you're gonna wear a little thong and
booty stuff out if I wanted to but
that's not how I guess I didn't that's
true
why would your boyfriend want to have a
an issue with that if if you were a
loyal girlfriend why could he not look
at you and think that's my girlfriend no
one else is [ __ ] touching her that is
the moment you wear that you put
yourself in a scenario where men are
actually going to touch you but why but
hang on
we're talking about particular garments
that are going to create scenarios
you're moving the goal post you can
dance where you want you can go where
you want you can do what you want
you have this you could say you could
say Oh by putting that watching you're
putting in a scenario where you could
get wrong of course you are what hold up
hold up hold on a second hold on a
second hold on a second there has to be
it hold on I've got a diamond chain on
my neck it's worth a lot of money yeah
yeah if I decide to go walk around in
the middle of the night in some Hood
place and I get robbed yeah yeah who is
gonna feel sorry for me if I had it
swinging around my neck end of the day I
know what I'm doing so he puts myself in
a scenario I should be able to go
anywhere in the world and wear what I
want but we don't right so if I've got a
daughter and my sister I'm gonna teach
them to say babes you should be able to
wear what you want do what you want and
go what you want but we live in a world
where there's some evil people around
there's some demons right this is how
you teach your kids you don't teach them
that everything in the world should be
fine everything should be okay you teach
them the dangers and potential what can
happen what you guys do is you guys say
you know what nothing matters in life we
go out there when something bad happens
then you want to scream where is me I'm
saying actually look looking from a
different perspective we should be doing
things we should be mitigating scenarios
on things that can potentially happen
that's all I'm saying I have three
sisters bro no you're right
so so if you've got seven nieces would
you say to your niece you know what you
know what um where go on the Titans um a
little little Skirt walk in the middle
of of happiness but I just say you need
to be you need to be careful so you
wouldn't advise okay okay so when
there's a caveat you said we don't care
what she wears no but you did it again
you said wear what you want but be
careful of your surroundings so there is
a caveat bruv if you have this if you
have this so they don't care if she's I
don't care if she's going to London Kent
or whatever no guys he is right on what
he says how men think because I went to
Carnival for example and then these guys
were coming up trying to talk to me and
I thought oh sorry I've got a man and
then they were like well where's your
man so I'll be honest with you I don't
care what club you go to I can't
wait
you're saying classy yeah not once she
mentioned classic there's a difference
between classy and skimpy you said
skimpy he wouldn't have a problem with
his woman looking at Classy yeah okay
that's why I asked about hang on a
minute that's why Arts of perception so
you can't now turn around and say classy
nobody's complaining about it
what I'm saying is yeah they're talking
about it doesn't what they're trying to
say is about perception about it doesn't
matter where you are some men are going
to try and move to you I don't care what
scenario we're in I don't care if you're
in a five-star higher class private
event and you're dressed from head to
toe in some lovely garment some man is
going to try and move to but it's how
they move to you
it matters
how you conduct yourself and who you are
with actually hang in a minute excuse me
young lady I'm terrible with names so
forgive me why did you stop
when you said that how you used to be
compared to now that you've stopped
certain things why did you stop the
reason I stopped because I realized I
don't like certain I wouldn't like
certain things so I just then had to
just look at the bigger picture like if
I wouldn't want him doing that then I
wouldn't do it myself did he tell you to
stop no did he ask you no if he did then
I probably wouldn't have right yeah so
you've done it because you wanted to do
it just consider it when you're in a
relationship things are different so
what make what made it different just
because I mean if you went out and you
were wearing no I know you said you
don't know I know you said you don't
wear skimpy clothes I know you said that
but the people you move with the things
that you do the places that you go to I
only have a few friends so I still like
I'm with the same friends but I just
mean like in terms of if I didn't have a
man then I could be out all the time all
the time all the time but obviously now
I'm in a relationship I'm more with him
so I'm not like outside you know what I
mean how do you feel in yourself I feel
good are you missing out no do you feel
more secure yeah I'm fine how's your
lunch with your man now you now you
don't go out so much that's good and I'm
obviously saving money sir
is it better yeah so as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible